it is the biggest anti-terrorism raid in
Germany for many years on Wednesday
morning some 3 000 police raided more
than 100 properties in several German
states and arrested 25 people all of
them suspected members or supporters of
the so-called reisberger movement their
goal a coup d'etat in Germany they
wanted to overthrow democracy
Germany's interior Minister Nancy feza
said the investigations provided a
glimpse into the quote abyss of a
terrorist threat from the iceberg Emilio
members of the militant reisberger scene
are united in the hatred of democracy of
our state and of people who stand up for
our community this is why we're taking
action against such Endeavors with all
the consequences of the rule of law
if they had succeeded this man was to
become the new head of state Heinrich a
descendant of an aristocratic family
from Eastern Germany who still uses the
symbolic title of Prince Heinrich the
13th the entrepreneur from Frankfurt is
said to be the ringleader
she would have been installed as the new
Justice Minister birgit mazak winkamman
who was a member of the German
Parliament for the far-right alternative
for Germany party until last year
she has since resumed working as a judge
at a Berlin Court efforts to remove her
from her position because of her
involvement with far-right extremists
failed earlier this year
the reisberger a far-right extremist
deeply anti-democratic movement its
members reject the German state and its
democratic system and are prone to
violence
German authorities estimate that the
scene consists of some 20 000 people
between 2015 and mid-2017 alone more
than 10 500 crimes are said to have been
committed by so-called heisberger
ndw political correspondent Julia
saudeli is at the scene of one of those
raids Julia tell us a little bit more
about the searches and arrests Where You
Are
yes this is uh where the one member of
of the network who was a former member
of parliament for the afd far-right
party and who is still a working judge
here in Berlin this is where she was
arrested and where her her house was
searched and we've we there's still
police present you can probably see here
behind me we see police officers going
in and out of the house but a lot of the
possessions that were found in the house
colleagues here told me were taken out
earlier quite a lot of things and bags
and boxes and taken away from here but
there is still some police activity
going on but the raids have been going
on since the early hours of the morning
this is only one of many raids today
what is known about the suspects and
their motives
so we've heard that um there are 25
people who have been arrested and but
there are still another 27 people who
are suspected of being a part of of this
network and we've heard also from the
piece that the supposed ringleader of
this network was uh this um descendant
of this Noble family who is also an
entrepreneur in Frankfurt and uh the
plan of this group was to basically uh
overthrow uh the current uh Democratic
order in Germany they had planned to
storm the German Parliament with weapons
and uh put up a rest of politicians and
and that way disrupt the Democratic
order they had already started setting
up what looked like a shadow government
that would then take power once they had
carried out the coup they were
organizing shooting trainings for their
members they were trying to enlist new
members especially those belonging to
the armed for forces and to the police
who have weapons and are trained to use
them
how real was the threat of a coup
against the German government
well we hear that the network started
forming at the latest in November of
last year and that investigations in the
network started in Spring of this year
when authorities received a tip from the
intelligence service of the state of
hessen here in Germany and the the group
had already started planning all of this
in practice and the the intentions of
this group were quite significant they
really planned to put in place a coup
and the ringleader of this group had
already according to the prosecutors
reached out for example to
representatives of Russia here in
Germany while the because the group saw
Russia as the one country who could help
them negotiate this new order new
government that they wanted to install
in Germany and also given the size of
this operation to dismantle this group
it seems like the threat was quite
significant Julia saudeli in Berlin
thank thank you